good afternoon so we never finished this
guy last time why is this wrong why is
this toy wrong so remember what virus
this is HIV it's got a label on it so
can you do you remember anything we
talked about last time that would tell
you that this is incorrect you know if
any of you ever start a company to do
this one day you'll get it right this is
not right
it's Ranney to anyone no it has an
envelope so what's what about this tells
you that it probably doesn't have an
envelope the pointy
it looks like an icosahedron right it's
not supposed to it should be a morphus
in fact but you see a nice fivefold axis
of symmetry here at the bottom right you
shouldn't see that right right now there
are remember there are some structured
envelopes some viruses where the
envelope is structured and you can see
the glycoproteins taking on the
underlying symmetry because they
interact with the capsid but this isn't
one of them HIV is not structured it's
unstructured shouldn't have any of this
symmetry so I think it's great that they
want to engage people with viruses but
they really need to get it right okay
before we go on to entry of viruses into
cells I want to mention one thing from
last time I showed you this slide to
explain how capsid proteins assemble
into virus-like particles and we used
the examples of the HPV and the human
papilloma virus vaccines you just need
to express one or a few viral proteins
and they assemble they self assemble
into a capsid and that's shown here and
these are vaccines that are made this
way now someone said someone asked me
can you express the it for a helical
capsid can you express those proteins
that bind to the RNA and will they form
a capsid and I said no and that's
correct but those viruses that have
helical symmetry like influenza
there are other ways to make virus-like
particles and one example is for
influenza which we haven't talked about
much we will
it has glycoproteins in its membrane and
it's lipid envelope and one of them is
called the hemagglutinin it's a very
important one which we'll learn about
today it attaches to the cell receptor
if you just Express the hemagglutinin in
cells you will get viral particles or
just the hemagglutinin the membrane
glycoprotein is enough to make the
particles form and we'll talk about how
they form later on in assembly but so in
fact some influenza virus like particle
vaccines are being tested right now and
they're made simply by expressing the
hemagglutinin in a cell alright so there
are other ways besides making a capsid
protein or it doesn't work with these
proteins that make the helical nucleic
acids but it will work with proteins
that are in the membrane now for other
viruses you can express other proteins
so for flu you express the H a you get
particles for HIV there's an internal
protein actually within this there's a
capsid and it's a shell basically and
it's made up of a protein called gag and
if you express gag
you also get virus-like particles made
ok so again there are many ways to do
this I want to leave you with the idea
that you can't do it for viruses with
helical symmetry ok in fact you can do
this for flu in plants plants in tobacco
you can express the H a of influenza in
tobacco plants and make vaccines out of
it you get particles and these vaccines
are being tested and the reason why it's
interesting is because because it's very
cheap to do this and I think a square
meter of tobacco plants will give you
$20,000 of flu vaccine it's very cheap
whereas you need one egg to make a dose
of flu vaccine that's much costlier ok
today we're going to talk about
attachment and entry of virus isn't to
sell so they know a little bit about
their structure we're gonna talk about
how they get in and what is this about
metastability how do we get over this
metastable barrier
now why do we have to get into a cell
well viruses of course are obligate
intracellular parasites they need to get
inside the cell to take advantage of all
the machinery that they need to
translate to replicate their genomes and
build new particles all right but
they're too big to diffuse across the
membrane
no virus particle can just diffuse in so
they have to be active ways of getting
them into the cell and that coupled with
the second point the virion is
metastable is the theme for today so the
virion has to be very stable as we said
yesterday to travel in the environment
but it s at some point in the cell it
has to open up it has to be metastable
and that property we'll talk about today
we'll talk about what triggers the virus
to become unstable
so when viruses do infect cells they
collide randomly with them they don't
actually seek a cell they have no way of
doing so they are just finding cells by
chance that's one of the reasons viruses
have to make so many progeny because
it's a chance event to encounter a cell
that they can replicate in viruses have
no powers of locomotion they can't sense
a cell and move towards it they're
totally dependent on randomness Brownian
motion diffusion electrostatic
interactions at finding cells and in
fact they find anything that's around
they bind junk they found debris as well
as cells so that's that's why there have
to be a lot of virus particles in part
because this is a random process and
also because the viruses can bind junk
for example in your respiratory tract
you have a lot of mucus and that mucus
has receptors for influenza virus in it
so virus influenza virus bumps into that
mucus and binds it and there's no cell
there for it to replicate in so the
virus is gone so binding junk can be a
protective mechanism in fact when
viruses interact when they bump into a
cell
the initial binding of the virus is
independent of temperature but the
binding it can happen at high or low
temperatures but it is influenced by
factors
pH the ionic strength of the medium and
particularly specific ions and in the
laboratory we use low temperature to
synchronize infection so we can attach
viruses to cell say at zero degrees
centigrade on ice four degrees all the
viruses will bind very well but they
will stay on the surface of the cell
because the uptake of viruses into cells
is energy dependent and doesn't occur at
four degrees so you can saturate your
cell with virus particles and then warm
them up to 37 degrees and they will all
enter synchronously so it's a very nice
way of synchronizing the entry process
so we take advantage of that so how does
a virus find the right cell well it has
to of course find a cell to begin with
and it will adhere to the cell surface
now it is drawn close to the cell by
electrostatic interactions but these
have no specificity and if there is no
receptor for the virus the virus cannot
replicate in that cell in order to
replicate the virus has to attach to a
cell that has a specific receptor
molecule sometimes more than one may be
involved not just in numbers of one kind
of receptor there may be multiple
receptor molecules different kinds and
then finally the genome has to get in
the cell so the cells the viruses are
moving around randomly they bump into
cells there are electrostatic
interactions that bring this out the
virus is closer they attach to a
receptor and then they that the genome
is somehow transferred inside the cell
and you'll see examples of where the
genome is transferred right at the
plasma membrane in other cases the
particle gets into the south we'll talk
about those today now a few words about
virus receptor interactions of course
the virus is the ligand in this case
it's a big lag in the receptor is
usually much smaller than the virus
particle and when we talk about virus
receptor interactions we talk about
affinity the strength of an interaction
between a single receptor and a single
recent virus
19 so it's the sum of the forces between
the two components so here we've
schematized a receptor interacting with
a single viral protein not the entire
virus but just one viral protein that
attaches to it high affinity
interactions have significant attractive
forces and low affinity have both
attractive and repulsive forces between
the protein of the virus and the
receptor avidity x' is a measure of the
overall binding of the receptor to the
virus particle and it involves multiple
binding sites and it's influenced by how
many sites exist on the receptor and the
ligand and viruses are particularly
influenced by this because they have
multiple receptor binding sites remember
virus particles are repetitive they are
the same proteins repeated over and over
so any virus buying any receptor binding
site is going to be repeated many times
as well and usually avidity is more than
the sum of the individual affinities so
if the in this example it shows an
antibody molecule binding to an antigen
the affinity for one antigen binding the
antibodies 10 to the fourth but when you
add to this now is described in terms of
avidity and the avidity has an affinity
as a constant of 10 to the sixth and if
you add more interactions it goes up in
even higher so it's not a simple sum the
avidity is not just a sum of the
infinite ease now in terms of viruses
that reaction we just looked at was not
a viral reaction but viruses in general
have low affinities for their receptors
but because there are multiple
interactions of receptors with virus
attachment protein fluidity is high so
for example you can have at least five
or six receptors interacting with
icosahedral virus particles and even if
the affinity is for the individual virus
protein receptor interaction is low the
avidity can be high so the virus sticks
effectively to the cell surface so it's
because of the multi marek nature of
this interaction that that is so now
cellular receptors for viruses are sent
for all viruses except those of yeasts I
crossed out fungi here because that's
not correct there are by viruses of
other kinds of fungi mushrooms for
example that have extra cellular
particles but yeast viruses don't exist
as extracellular particles they're
transmitted within the cell as the cell
divide the viral nucleic acid is
transmitted from cell to cell so in fact
there's no extracellular phase plant
viruses there are extra cellular
particles but they don't in enter plant
cells by interacting with receptors they
are usually introduced by mechanical
damage farm equipment running over
plants it breaks them the viruses get in
or vectors of various sorts insect
vectors and other parasites introduce
viruses plant viruses into plants so no
receptors are involved just for animal
viruses and other kinds of animal
viruses we'll leave it at that we have
often receptors and co-receptors many
viruses need just one protein on the
cell surface one type of protein others
need multiple and we say usually it's a
receptor in a co-receptor but that's
kind of a misnomer because who's to say
that one is the boss and the other is a
co boss right they could both be
receptors but at the nomenclature is in
the literature to distinguish the two
usually depends which one was discovered
first the first one is the receptor and
the second one is the co receptor as ly
as recently as 1985 only one virus
receptor was known and that is sialic
acid for influenza virus we'll talk
about that but at about that time
cloning DNA mediated transformation the
production of monoclonal antibodies all
arrived on the scene and that made it
possible to identify a lot of different
receptors so nowadays we have receptors
for just about every virus that we work
with how do you identify receptors the
reason why that was difficult to
identify them is be up until 1985 when
we had this technology is because people
tried to use biochemical approaches they
would try to take a cell and solubilize
the membrane proteins and fraction ate
them and see what binds virus and this
was just very inefficient
the affinities are very low and it
wasn't it was very difficult to identify
any receptors but we'll have genetic
approaches we can identify them quite
readily and so these are three different
approaches for using genetics to
identify a viral receptor so we start
with a cell that doesn't have a receptor
it's a an important reagent if you will
you have a cell that it doesn't bind
your virus so it's not susceptible it
doesn't have a receptor but it's
permissive which means that if you can
put the nucleic acid of your virus in
that cell the virus will replicate so
poke beyond the receptor binding this
cell is completely supportive of virus
replication that's not often easy to
find but if you have it it helps you
clone receptors then you take another
cell which isn't shown here and that has
a receptor for your virus so if it has a
receptor it must have a gene encoding
that receptor right assuming it's a
protein so then you take DNA from those
cells that express your receptor and you
put it into these receptor negative
cells by DNA mediated transformation and
you do that because you would like to
now have that gene encoding the receptor
expressed in these receptor negative
cells so that you can eventually
identify it of course if you infect
those cells that have been transformed
with DNA you're going to kill them the
ones that have the receptor you're going
to kill and you won't have them anymore
so that's not very useful so you have to
design clever ways to try and identify
the cells that have a receptor and
they're a couple of ways indicated here
one you could if you have an antibody to
the receptor so you could screen for
antibodies that block virus attachment
and presumably some of those will be
directed against your receptor you could
add those to your transform cells and
pick out the ones that expressed the
receptor on the cell surface you could
do that by flow cytometry or any of a
variety of other ways when we we cloned
the receptor for polio in my lab many
years ago so I came to Columbia and saw
silverstein develop had developed a way
of putting DNA into cells and I say
could we use this to clone a receptor
for a virus and he said yeah so we did
and we made DNA from susceptible cells
we put it into cells that didn't have
the receptor and then we we happen to
find someone who had an antibody to the
receptor and we took that antibody we
coupled it to red blood cells red blood
cells are very big and then if you put
those on top of these transform ins you
can easily see in a culture dish the
ones that are binding red blood cells
just under a microscope so we pick those
and grew them up and sure enough they
were susceptible to polio infection so
you can use antibodies now if you have a
virus that is not killing yourself like
retroviruses you can put genes into
those viruses which then you can find in
the transform cell so here for example
you add a recombinant virus carrying a
drug resistance gene so only the cells
that have a receptor will take up that
virus and you put drug on those cells it
kills all the cells that haven't been
infected and the ones that are left now
have the drug resistance gene delivered
by the virus and then you can clone out
the gene from them very easily and then
you could use an indicator you could put
green fluorescent protein into your
virus as well and then sort out the
green cells so lots of ways these are
just three but having these DNA based
approaches really opened up the field
and we now have lot as I said lots and
lots of virus receptors identified and
so here are some of the criteria that we
have developed for identifying cell
receptors you can have a monoclonal
antibody so you take cells that have
your receptor you raise monoclonal
antibodies against them
and then you identify the ones that
block infection and you say okay these
are these are interesting they could be
against the receptor but they might not
be so it's not enough just to have a
monoclonal you can imagine that here you
have a receptor for your virus and next
to it is a very close other protein and
maybe your monoclonal is there against
that protein and they sterically block
virus attachment so a monoclonal doesn't
necessarily identify the receptor if you
take that monoclonal and identify the
protein and clone its gene and you show
that expression of that gene in a Cell
can
susceptibility then the case is even
better so if DNA encoding the protein
makes the cell susceptible it's good but
on its own it's not enough let's say you
you have a gene and you put it into a
cell and it makes it susceptible to your
virus and you want to publish a paper
saying this is the receptor a reviewer
may say well what if you actually need
two proteins to get into the cell and
this is just one of them and the other
ones already present in the cell and to
which you put your DNA so you're kind of
being misled by the fact that that one
DNA or that one gene is enough to confer
infection so each of these on its own is
not sufficient to but when you put them
together then you have a strong case
some in some cases different viruses
bind the same receptor so for example
adenoviruses which are DNA viruses
coxsackievirus b3 which is an RNA virus
named after Coxsackie new york his exit
21 beyond the New York Thruway right I
was driving up you know I've drove past
this many times in my years of doing
biology and I said I have to take a
picture of that and finally two years
ago I was driving and I picked up my
camera and did it so that's going at 60
miles an hour
Coxsackie New York because these viruses
were first identified there it's a very
interesting story they both have a
common primary receptor to--to two
totally different viruses different
structures different nucleic acids they
have a common they use the same receptor
swine herpes virus pseudo rabies virus
binds the same receptor as human
poliovirus totally different viruses and
so those are examples where two
different viruses buying the same
receptors sometimes virus of the same
family nine different receptors the
Rhino viruses there are over a hundred
of them there are three different
receptors identified so far and
retroviruses there are 16 different cell
surface molecules that serve as
receptors so it's not just one receptor
one virus you can forget about that kind
of thinking because all the rules are
broken here are some examples of
corner virus receptors just to give you
an idea of what these proteins look like
at least in a you know line drawing
that's many of them are I do like
immunoglobulin like proteins
you know the antibody molecule when it
was discovered years ago was showed to
have a specific kind of protein fold and
that was named an immunoglobulin fold
and it turns out that other proteins
other than antibodies have the same fold
and it's shown here as a loop and some
of the per corner receptors as well as
receptors for other viruses are IG like
protein here's the polio receptor has
three domains and others have more or
fewer the HIV receptor is a protein like
this as well cd4 these are transmembrane
proteins so they have a part this is the
cell surface the plasma membrane there's
a part of these proteins that's in the
extracellular part there's the
transmembrane domain and then it's
usually a tail we call it a cytoplasmic
tail a short stretch of protein that
goes into the cell cytoplasm some of the
proteins are not transmembrane proteins
like this one the receptor for a number
of enterovirus it is anchored to the
membrane by a GPI the linkage of
phosphatidyl inositol linkage so it
doesn't traverse the membrane and there
are all kinds of proteins that serve as
receptors not just a single family like
IG like proteins all kinds so viruses
randomly to select from whatever on the
cell surface to utilize when they get
into cells now here's a question that
always comes up are these receptors here
for the viruses benefit is that their
sole function in the cell what do you
think I see a lot of nose right everyone
agree with that or do you think they're
there for viruses no of course not
they're there because they have a
function in the cell and the viruses
have evolved to utilize them so these
all have specific functions in the cell
for example these a lot of these IG like
molecules are adhesion proteins they are
functioning in the adhesion of cells and
tissues
these are integrants which have roles in
immune responses so they're not there
for the virus so let's take a look at
how a receptor would interact with a
virus that has an icosahedron shell and
I'll just turn this off briefly so you
can see this this is the receptor for
poliovirus
it is a transmembrane protein with 3 IG
like domains you can see here and it
interacts with the virus which is shown
up here there's a there's a little
depression in the surface of the
icosahedral capsid I don't if you
remember I showed you at the very
beginning a structure of polio I said
there are cavities and Peaks on this and
in fact one of those cavities is where
the receptor binds and this is the
fivefold axis of symmetry so around each
fivefold axis there are five copies of
the protein that make it up and there
are five binding sites for the receptor
and we know that this is the way the
receptor binds is because a number of
years ago we took with poliovirus which
is in red and blue and yellow and we
mixed it with a purified version of the
receptor without membranes present and
did cryo-electron microscopy to solve
the structure of the complex so this is
the complex of polio with the receptors
which are all in grey or grayish blue
you can see that there are five of them
around each fivefold axis so here is a
fivefold axis of symmetry one two three
four five receptors and you should be
able to calculate how many total
receptors could bind this particle right
because you know all about icosahedron
symmetry I'm gonna save that for a quiz
questions Michael you don't have to
answer it now it's very easy it's very
easy
so that is poliovirus the receptor fits
into this little groove now in contrast
here is rhinovirus binding to one of its
receptors and this receptor happens to
be the low-density lipoprotein receptor
which has a role in cholesterol
metabolism of course and here the
receptor is actually well it's also
around the fivefold axis of symmetry you
can see one two three four five grey
receptors sitting up there but it's not
in this little groove Rhino virus has a
similar groove
around its fivefold axis but it's up on
this Plateau if you will right up here
so it's sitting on top of the plateau at
the fivefold axis so there are many
different ways that a receptor can
interact with the virus particle as you
can see here now influenza virus also
binds to a receptor of course and that
is that is a very different receptor
that is a single molecule of sugar
called sialic acid
so here's influenza virus it's a
envelope the virus with two different
glycoproteins actually two different
glycoproteins and the third protein in
its membrane the hemagglutinin the h a
we'll talk about over and over in this
course is the protein that binds the
cell receptor alright that's when this
virus attaches to a cell as we're
showing here it is attaching via the
hemagglutinin and the receptor is on the
cell sciatic acid so here is sialic acid
and acetic acid so again your six carbon
ring
the typical sugar with various side
chains that make it sigh alloc acid now
silac acid is typically when it's used
as a receptor for influenza virus it is
present on a glycoprotein so here is an
example of a cell protein a
transmembrane protein in this case and
it's glycosylated it has sugars attached
to it and each of these little balls is
a different sugar and when sciatic acid
is present and it's present on all of
our tissues it's the last sugar in these
chains of sugars that are attached to
the proteins all right so say Allah cast
it's always the terminal sugar and that
is the sugar to which influenza binds
sialic acid it doesn't matter what the
rest of the sugar is it doesn't matter
what the protein is all that matters is
silac acid and in fact we have silac
acids in in our mucus and that serves as
a good foil for influenza as it tries to
infect us because the virus will bind
those free sialic acids and not be able
to bind to a cell there are three types
of influenza viruses which we will talk
about more later a B and C and they have
slightly different receptors a and
recognized a NASA teal neuro minute so
that's the asset teal group attached to
the nitrogen and the C viruses
recognized nine o acetylated newer
Minich acid not important to chemical
structures just that there are different
receptors this is actually an alpha to
three linked sialic acid the desai acid
is linked to the next sugar which in
this case is a galactose by an alpha to
three linkage and there are also alpha
to six linkages where it would be linked
to this carbon up here this alyc acid be
linked to that one and influenza viruses
use both of them but there are species
differences so human influenza viruses
preferentially like to attach to alpha
to six linked sialic acids we do have
alpha two three three linked silac acids
in our respiratory attack but they tend
to be in our lungs lower down in the
tracked avian influenza viruses prefer
alpha to three linked sialic acids and
this is interesting because you know
that they're highly pathogenic avian
influenza viruses that many people are
frightened of because we're afraid that
they're gonna infect and kill all of us
and they in order for them to infect us
they have to get way down into your lung
okay either that or adapt to using an
alpha to six silac acid so we will talk
about that later
a little more but the fact is that flu
can recognize two different types of
linkages in the silac acid and their
species differences here is how the
sialic acid binds to the hemagglutinin
this is a structure that has been solved
by x-ray crystallography you take the H
a purified from the virus you mix it
with silac acid you do the crystal
structure of x-ray crystallography here
is the hemagglutinin protein so here's
the the viral membrane and the
hemagglutinin is a very interesting
extended protein it consists of a stalk
or a fibrous stem onto which there is a
globular head and the head is the
business end of this molecule it
contains the sialic acid binding site
right up here and here on the right is a
close view of
like acid which is shown here in green
which is binding in the pocket and you
can see it interacts with a variety of
amino acids in the hemagglutinin so it's
evolved to have a high affinity binding
site in there well it's a reasonably
good affinity but remember the virus can
bind to multiple silac acids on the cell
as it attaches so it has a good avidity
even even though this is not terrific
all right so that's the sialic acid
binding site on the head of the
hemagglutinin molecule all right HIV is
will leave the light off for this
another virus similar to flu in that
it's envelope with glycoproteins on the
surface that attach to cell receptors
one thing you notice here in this
cartoon is that there not a lot of
glycoproteins on the surface of the HIV
virion and and that may be in part where
it's hard to neutralize these viruses
effectively but these are the viral
glycoproteins there but trimers here in
yellow and they actually attach to both
a receptor and a co-receptor you need
both for this virus to infect cells so
flu many other viruses one receptor
interaction is enough for HIV you need
to to do that you need the receptor for
seed for the virus which is cd4 and the
co receptor which was discovered later
which is a receptor for chemokines in
the south now what do we have here okay
so this is a drawing of the interaction
of HIV with its receptor here's the
cellular receptor for HIV this is the
primary receptor cd4 the yellow is the
part where the viral glycoprotein is
going to interact and here is a
structure of the viral glycoprotein and
this is the part of the protein that is
sort of a cavity which is going to sit
down on top of this receptor here's a
cartoon of how that works so this is the
viral glycoprotein here and this is the
cellular receptor it fits down on top of
it very nicely other viruses also are
interesting to think about in terms of
how they attach this is adenovirus which
we've looked at a few times it is a
large DNA virus with an icosahedral
shell and remember this photograph with
the antennae coming out that's that's
here there are 12 of those fibers and at
the end of each fiber there's a knob and
that knob interacts with the cell
receptor for adenovirus and this is the
structure of that knob it's a trimer so
it's one protein repeated three times
and it makes it has a nice little area
in the middle which is conserved and
which interacts with the cell receptor
which is the same one shared with
coxsackievirus so here you have an
icosahedral virus member polio is
icosahedral the receptor though sits
down into a groove and the capsid but
here adenovirus has these fibers
sticking out so it's a different way of
attaching an icosahedral virus all right
so that's attachment that's just the
first step this is a way of getting a
virus to the right cell because the
right cell has the receptor that the
virus has evolved to interact with then
the virus has to get into the cell
because it's nucleic acid needs to go
there so let's talk about how that
happens virus is just usurped cellular
pathways cells are very good at taking
up things from the extracellular medium
they have to be able to do that to
survive here are two general ways that
they do that they take up large
particles by phagocytosis but we're not
going to consider that today because
that's not how viruses get into the
cells they usually get in by some form
of endocytosis and this is the way cells
take up smaller material so a subset of
endocytosis is called pinocytosis the
membrane of a cell is always pinching in
invaginate and taking up components of
the extracellular medium it's also
called cellular drinking it's their way
of getting small molecules into the cell
it's not specific
it's whatever ends up being in these
vesicles as they invasion ate and
pinched off this is a continuous process
many cells do this all the time a good
fraction of their plasma membrane is
always imaginating and bringing material
in there's a variant of this called
receptor mediated endocytosis and this
there are specific receptors for ligands
on the cell surface that the VAR that
the cell wants to bring in and when
those ligands bind that stimulates the
endocytic pathway so this is not
constitutive this only occurs when
the ligand is bound and these are taken
up into vesicles which eventually
proceed into the cell till viruses usurp
this pathway to get it and not all of
them do but many of them do as you will
see now to move yes this one now this is
just a ligand that sells something that
the cell wants to take up there are
receptors for various compounds in in
the extracellular fluids that the cell
wants to bring in and so there is a
process endocytosis that is evolved to
do that it's the same pathway that the
virus is used so this is not a virus
it's just illustrating whatever the
ligand
well yes if there is a natural ligand
such as this the virus would compete
with it
to get in sure now once when the virus
is moving into the cell via this Indesit
ik pathway one thing you have to
remember is that this kind of a picture
of the cytoplasm is really wrong I mean
I don't show anything here but these
vesicles so you may think these vesicles
could just diffuse wherever they want
easily but it's not the case because the
cytoplasm is really crowded so here's a
drawing of the cytoplasmic by an artist
David Goodell who's out at Scripps who
likes to draw biological things and
here's the plasma membrane and then
these are sections moving towards the
nucleus then you can see all kinds of
actin structures microfilaments
endoplasmic reticulum Golgi there's some
ribosomes in here here's a nuclear pore
so we're moving down towards the nucleus
here's a nuclear pore and there are
things moving in and then we have
nucleosomes DNA wrapped into nucleus
ohms here so it's really crowded all
right and you can't just randomly move
around it has to be some kind of active
transport to move a vesicle from the
plasma membrane to wherever it has to go
in the cell even if it just needs to go
near the plasma membrane they're acting
microfilaments there that are very dense
and you have to be able to get through
that so there are processes that get
around this and we'll talk about them
but he
the next slide is an interesting numbers
game where this this individual data so
they did some calculations on how fast
viral components would could just
diffuse in a cell so she took the she
calculated this by determining the
radius of the particle and the viscosity
of water and then assuming that the
cytoplasm would be 500 the diffusion
constants would be 500 times lower than
in water which yes has some basis so
here for example the time to travel 10
microns it's a very short distance for
poliovirus in water 3.8 five seconds but
in the cytoplasmic would take a half
hour for the same thing to happen so to
get from the plasma membrane maybe near
the nucleus would take a half hour
herpes simplex 14 seconds in water two
hours in the cytoplasm vaccinia and
these are increasingly larger viruses 35
seconds in the in water and almost 5
hours in the cytoplasm so 5 hours is too
long it's not efficient so there are
active pathways that's what the point is
here and these are summarized on the
next slide they require cellular
transport machinery so here's a summary
of some of those and there are very
specific ways that vesicles and acidic
vesicles get into the cell via this from
the cell surface yeah
I think it's roughly the maybe it
depends you know if it's a flat cell and
a cell culture dish versus a round sound
suspension but it's roughly the this the
height of a cell growing on a tissue
culture this yeah that's the point of
that calculation how long it would take
to get to get into the deep part of the
cell so here are some pathways that
viruses use and we'll talk about some of
these some some viruses fuse right at
the cell surface but they still have to
get through this microfilament boundary
which is composed of action this is
quite dense composed of actin so virus
just can't pass through it has to do
something to disrupt it and there are
signaling pathways that are being
identified where virus binding to a
receptor causes the actin to dissociate
beneath it very interesting when viruses
get in by endocytosis those vesicles
don't just diffuse they attach to
microtubules and they are transported
towards the nucleus by motors motor
proteins so we have a number of examples
of that there are a variety of endo
Civic pathways here based on the protein
constituents
there's clathrin dependent endocytosis
clathrin and caviola
independent and caviola and dependent
just the variety they are just different
pathways based on the proteins that are
involved in them and viruses have
evolved to take all of them to get into
the cell so the point is that for
example influenza virus here is taken up
by endocytosis it's brought into the
cell by movement of these vesicles on
microtubules and some of these viruses
need to get close to the nucleus and
they can do so readily because the
centrosome is as close to there where
these microtubules appends and
eventually this brings the virus where
it needs to be so the point here again
you need to have active transport
pathways in order to bring components
into the nucleus into the cell to the
right place here are some pictures of
endocytosis for example here is the
early stage of invagination there is
there is a ligand bound to a receptor in
here and it is this the membrane is
starting to imaginate it's coated with
clathrin here a little bit more
extensive in VAT
eventually this pinches off to become a
vesicle which then is now an endosome
and then goes into the sewol what you
can't see here of course are the
microtubules on which this is tracking
into the south so early pictures such as
this were misleading because we we
thought they were just diffusing but in
fact they are tracking on microtubules
all right so this is a movie showing the
movement of an endosome this is a really
cool company ex vivo that does
scientific animation so here we have an
endosome right here and this is a
microtubule and it's going to be tracked
by this motor protein which is binding
the endosome as well as the microtubule
yeah this is very neat so this is
obviously a little artistic license but
this is the process by which these
endosomes come from the plasma membrane
down into the nucleus we'll see some
other versions of this as well to
describe specific virus entry now here
sometimes viruses will fuse right at the
plasma membrane and you don't need to be
taken up into an endosome and moved into
the cell and here is an example of one
of these measles virus does this these
are envelope 2 viruses with helical
genomes this virus fuses right at the
plasma membrane and so the nucleic acid
can get into the cytoplasm and that's
where it needs to be it doesn't have to
go to the nucleus if it had to be in the
nucleus it would have evolved to be
taken up by endocytosis and moved down
in microtubule track all right but this
virus that once the RNA is in the
cytoplasm it can start replicating but
as I said remember that we're not
showing any of those microfilaments here
so this is a little misleading it's not
easy to get from here to here there have
to be other steps as well now how this
fusion occurs there are a number of
mechanisms one of them is shown here
there is a viral glycoprotein it's
called the hn4 paramyxovirus --is which
interacts with a cellular receptor so
here for example the HN is recept is
interacting with a red protein on the
cell this is the cell receptor but
that's not enough to fuse the viral in
this
membrane just binding would not be
enough you have to have something else
to confer specificity because if this
virus fused with whatever it bumped into
you often get into cells in which you
couldn't replicate there is a second
glycoprotein on these viruses called the
F glycoprotein and this is a fusion
glycoprotein and enables vir it enables
membranes to fuse we'll talk about those
more in a moment this is the fusion part
is normally hidden but when this HN
binds its receptor it unfolds the fusion
protein so that can now stick into the
membrane and catalyze fusion right so
normally the fusion protein is masked
the binding of the H end to the cell
receptor causes a conformational change
in the fusion protein now the fusion
head flips out and sticks into the
membrane we'll look at that in more
detail in just a moment so this is the
scheme for this virus here measles virus
HIV also does a similar thing it fuses
at the plasma membrane here is a variant
of HIV and this is the glycoprotein that
is going to be involved in attachment
and fusion it has two components the TM
or transmembrane component and that has
the fusion peptide on the end and then a
su which stands for surface the su binds
the cellular receptor which is cd4 shown
in green here when that happens there is
a conformational change in su which then
allows it to bind the co receptor which
is shown here is the chemokine receptor
so this is a virus that needs two
distinct cellular receptors to get into
the cell once the co receptor and the
receptor both engaged with su then the
TM segment unfolds and the fusion
protein goes into the membrane so two
receptor requiring virus both of the Co
receptors interact with su it has to
happen in in sequence first cd4 has to
be engaged and then that allows su to
engage the chemokine receptor and this
again happens at the plasma membrane
this fusion is triggered right there and
the virus nucleic acid is deposited into
the cell now this is in contrast to a
mechanism we'll talk about in a moment
where some viruses get into the cell via
endocytosis and there's a different
trigger for fusion and that's low pH all
right but at the plasma membrane there's
no way to lower the pH of the
extracellular medium so there has to be
another trigger for fusion and that
trigger is engagement of a receptor or a
receptor and a co-receptor in unfolded
from the fusion protein so that in mind
in this case there's no acid involved
but there are still mechanisms to get
that fusion protein activated that was
their question yeah
the fusion peptide is what allows the
membranes to fuse so the you know you
have a virus membrane here and a plasma
membrane they have to fuse in order to
get the nucleic acid out of the particle
so the fusion protein is crucial for
that what I what I wanted to say was the
fusion protein can't be exposed all the
time because these viruses would be
fusing with any cell they bump into so
the fusion protein is hidden and it will
only be exposed when the receptor is
engaged so that gives it the specificity
ok that's if I didn't say that that's
what I meant to say right yes
do only viruses with envelopes have
fusion peptides only envelopes need to
fuse with host cells yes the viruses
with protein shells get in in different
ways as we'll see so they don't have
what we call fusion proteins they have
other mechanisms to encode so let's keep
a fusion protein in a fusion peptide
restricted to the fusion of the envelope
of the virus with the plasma membrane or
some other membrane in the cell okay yes
the f2 is all right so the in E and some
viruses the fusion peptide is actually
internal in the sequence it's this
squiggly line here and so it's another
way to protect it from reacting with
anything it bumps into so the way it's
exposed is these proteins have to be
cleaved by a protease that's usually a
cellular protease and that gives you an
end terminus which is the fusion peptide
and then when you get engagement of the
receptor and the fusion protein unfolds
then that that is exposed so if you
don't have cleavage even if you engage a
receptor if the protease isn't present
you will not infect the cell so it's
another level ensuring specificity yeah
exactly so they're held together by the
disulfides
and presumably there is some role in f2
and that's why it's kept there though
I'm not sure that we know that okay so
now we have a movie of HIV infecting a
cell and this is HIV right here
it's the glycoproteins on the surface
you can see there trimers and we're
going to see this engaging its cell
receptor here's a cd4 T positive T
lymphocyte that it's going to infect
some red blood cells around here for
size comparisons virus is diffusing in
your blood and here is the receptor
co-receptor complex on the cell surface
that's going to be in
aged this is cd4 and these are the
chemokine receptors very dramatic here's
the glycoprotein on the surface of the
virion this is the head which is going
to engage the receptors in here at the
back here is the fusion protein it's
folded back against the viral membrane
so it's hidden and you will see what
happens to that once they're engaged so
initially you see there's a binding site
for cd4 on the side of the head of the
glycoprotein swings around the lid off
and then it engages the CCR 4 or the CCR
receptor on the cell surface that
induces conformational changes now they
take away that so you'll get confused so
the F the fusion protein now unfolds and
inserts into the cell membrane so to get
fusion just requires that you bring
membranes very close together which is
energetically not easy because there's
water in there if you have to squeeze it
out so the unfolding of that fusion
protein is part of that process which is
not shown here eventually the membranes
come very close together and they will
fuse and release the core of the
particle which is shown here now that's
in the cytoplasm and eventually it will
come apart and the rest of the cycle
will occur of course there are a lot of
things missing from that but that gives
you a nice idea of how this is working
all right so that is at the cell surface
let's take a look at uncoding from an
endosome and and the example here is is
influenza virus which is the
best-studied
virus binds silac acid containing
proteins at the cell surface it's taken
up into the cell by the endocytic
pathway and as endosomes move into the
cell they become acidic protons are
pumped into the endosome to lower the pH
which activates a variety of processes
in the endosome for flu it's essential
for encoding eventually as the pH
reaches a certain part a certain level I
think it's about five five or so in the
endosome the hemagglutinin which is
shown here bound to silac acid so here's
hemagglutinin is the head of the
hemagglutinin bound
silac acid this is the endosome membrane
this is the viral membrane here the low
pH causes the heads to fall away here
and allows the unfolding of the fusion
peptide so here are three fuse this is a
trimer this hemagglutinin here are three
fusion peptides stuck in the membrane
these are initially folded down here so
here are the fusion peptides at the
bottom in this neutral pH state when the
pH drops the heads fall away and these
these HeLa C's actually extend very much
like the one for HIV there initially
folded they extend the fusion protein
goes into the endosome membrane and that
catalyzes the fusion of the membrane so
here that's shown at a larger scale the
pH is dropping the viral membrane fuses
with that of the endosome and that then
the nucleic acid of the virus can be out
in the cytoplasm all right so these two
membranes fused by this mechanism and
that lets the nucleic acids out now
these eventually have to get in the
nucleus and the way they do that is
through another protein in the membrane
that we've mentioned briefly the the m2
protein which is an ion channel present
in the virion itself now and as the
protons are pumped into the endosome
they are then again pumped into the
interior of the particle this
dissociates the riving grab a nuclear
proteins remember the other day we
showed these coils of RNA and protein
these have to be dissociated in order to
be able to get into the nucleus and the
protons that are pumped into the
interior of the particle do that and so
now these RNAs get into the nucleus
where they have to be replicated so flu
doesn't end doesn't stay in the
cytoplasm it can't replicate its genome
there has to get it into the nucleus so
this is how it fuses and how it gets the
nucleic acid first into the cytoplasm
and that into the nucleus this is a
diagram of the hemagglutinin in a
variety of stages this is the native
hemagglutinin here's the head that binds
sialic acid the fusion protein is down
here this is another kind of
glycoprotein where
cleavage has to occur in order for
fusion to work and the cleavage is
carried out by cellular proteases we'll
talk about that more later cleavage
occurs right here and then as you drop
the pH in the endosome the fusion
proteins which is shown the N term and I
here are the fusion proteins they flip
up and the fusion proteins are now
projected into the endosomal membrane so
here we've taken away all the other
change to clarify this this fusion
region right here is normally down here
and when the pH drops it flips up so it
can go in the membrane and that also
requires cleavage as well okay all of
these have been solved their structures
have all been solved at high resolution
that's why we know this and this is just
a schematic of the actual fusion event
here's our H a it binds to salic acid
receptor not shown here at low pH it
extends the fusion protein goes from
down here it extends into the endosome
membrane and it's a trimer of course now
the actual fusion comes about because
once these are extended they actually
Bend back down again this is called hair
pinning you can see that here the three
fusion proteins bend down we're not sure
what does that but they've been down
that and doing that brings the membranes
together so eventually they can fuse all
right so initially you have an extended
conformation which puts the fusion
protein in the distal membrane then the
hair pinning occurs which brings the
membranes very close together and when
you put two lipid bilayers right next to
each other you squeeze all the water out
they will fuse and that's what's
happening here so you can have this pore
and the nucleic acid so we know this
process at very high resolution because
we have structures of all these proteins
now this is analogous to what happens in
cells cells have to fuse membranes all
the time and they do so using snare
proteins which I presume you've learned
about in other courses these are
proteins that do similar things to the
info as the influenza virus
hemagglutinin so here's the flu h.a
doing its hair pinning braining bringing
the two membranes together and here the
cell snares do the same thing and
they're called viral hairpins and
cellular
snare pins so these have probably one
who has evolved from the other which we
don't know fusion proteins are
classified in two ways class one the H a
is one of those they are perpendicular
to the membrane and when you look at
them in an electron micrograph they look
like spikes and that's why the early e/m
photographs and caused us to use that
name spike glycoproteins they're mostly
alpha helical and they make trimers and
here are some examples of those
influenza virus h a we've talked about
other paramyxovirus as Ebola virus HIV
Mouse retrovirus the glycoproteins with
diffusion potential are all
perpendicular to the membrane there
trimers and they have a fusion peptide
which is normally buried and which is
exposed upon the right trigger class to
fusion proteins are very different
they're mostly beta sheet so here these
are all alpha helixes here that
constitute the majority of these
proteins the class two are mostly beta
sheet they form dimers and the most
important thing they're parallel to
their brains this is very interesting
how can a protein that's parallel to the
membrane engage in fusion now you can
see for the flu h a which is
perpendicular makes perfect sense
because when you flip up the fusion
protein it goes into the distal membrane
that has that work for these class two
so there are many interesting viruses
including West Nile virus tick-borne
encephalitis protein that have these
horizontally oriented fusion proteins
here is a diagram of dengue virus with
one of them fitted in you can see all
the fusion proteins are lying on the
virus surface the trigger for the fusion
for these viruses is also low pH and
here are two different ways that these
fusion proteins cause fusion here at the
top is an alpha virus fusion protein
these are the the beta sheets of the
fusion proteins of the glycoproteins I
should say you could see the fusion
proteins are right at the end now these
are a bit exposed all right so they have
to be covered by a second viral
glycoprotein which is shown here
in red so there there are a couple of
strategies you could use to hide a
fusion protein one is you could fold it
back and keep it near the membrane in
this case a second viral protein covers
it again so it just doesn't fuse with
everything it encounters when the pH and
the endosome drops these red proteins
move away conformational change mediated
by low pH and the protein containing the
fusion peptide which is exposed Orient's
itself perpendicularly and causes fusion
so that's for the Alpha viruses the
flavor viruses are lying flat these
attachment proteins are lying flat on
the cell surface as the pH changes they
move up so they're sufficiently
protected here from random fusing so you
see the parallel arrangement is is sort
of a way of keeping the fusion peptide
hidden and this is a diagram of how that
would work I showed you this for the flu
H I want to show it to you for these
horizontally oriented fusion proteins as
the pH drops these proteins reorient to
a to a vertical orientation shown here
the fusion peptides insert into the
distal membrane just like the flu h a
and then they hairpin this folds back
down on itself draws the two membranes
together it's not shown very well here
but it draws the two membranes down just
as it does for H a a flu so even though
it's horizontal the mechanism is very
similar Fusion is regulated we've talked
a little bit about this because you
don't want it to happen in the wrong
place you want it to happen only in
cells that have the right receptor and
that the virus can infect and so for
class one proteins proteolytic cleavage
typically activates the protein for
fusion remember we looked at two
specific cases where the n-terminus has
to be released by a cleavage otherwise
fusion will not occur for the class two
proteins often cleavage of a second
protein activates fusion we haven't
shown that but that's the case
eventually low pH in both types of
protein will trigger fusion but it won't
happen unless the cleavage has occurred
either of the protein itself as for the
class
one or the second protein for class -
yeah I put this up here why do I put
this up here to remind you that
influenza virus goes through this same
pathway it goes through low pH mediated
fusion the viral envelope fuses with the
endosome membrane the ribonucleoprotein
or the helical RNA is released and goes
into the nucleus so I have a movie of
this that I want to show you and look at
this very carefully because I want you
to tell me what's wrong with it
I love finding these artistic errors but
it's actually instructive to do so so
this is a movie called influenza virus
entry let's see what this looks like
alright so they're depicting the the
entry of flu into a cell they're
assembling a vy what's wrong with that
all right you can tell me later
so this is purportedly an influenza
virus that is the capsid within the
envelope here oh the glycoproteins on
the surface here the virus moving around
your respiratory tract it's going to
attach to a receptor
taken up by clathrin-coated vesicles you
see the nice clathrin structure there
eventually the clathrin is gonna come
off and it's riding down a microtubule
very quickly clathrin is coming off now
still you have it so that's an endosome
containing your virus and there's the
fusion event and those are the
ribonucleoproteins
which are now going to go into the
nucleus through the nuclear pores if you
will okay so that's the same thing
repeating itself so anyone want to guess
what's wrong with it
right there is the problem one of the
problems No
how about when it comes apart that's
that's a bit later on
this is okay so we had one problem we're
reading there's going to be a second one
they're just too
yeah
yeah they're showing it as having a
capsid right which okay no the RNA and
the RNA proteins remain together it's
it's another protein that comes off but
that's okay the the capsid is one issue
it doesn't have a capsid as a nucleo
capsid and they're showing it as an
icosahedral structure if you look at the
movie and you'll have it on the file you
can see that when it comes apart it
comes apart in triangles and that's
typical of an icosahedral structure
right each face of the icosahedron is a
triangle and flu does not have an
icosahedral capsid just like HIV doesn't
have an icosahedron caption so that's
not correct and the way it comes apart
isn't depicted correctly okay a couple
other viruses to talk about how they get
in because they're quite interesting
this is Sam Leakey forest virus does
anybody know what Sam Leakey means no do
you know Saul really after hearing me so
many years you don't have a clue
well the story the story goes yes there
are many dumb the story goes that this
virus was discovered in Africa and the
virologist who discovered it asked his
guide in the area where he had found it
he said what's the name of this place
and the guide said Sam Leakey so he
called it Sam Leakey forest virus but
Sam Leakey means forest
the guy said we're in the forest so now
we have a forest forest virus this is a
well studied virus because the particle
the pfu ratio you remember that know
that the particle the PSU ratio of this
virus is one to one so it's very nice to
study anyway this has taken up it binds
the receptors taken up by endocytosis
the pH of the endosome drops there's a
viral membrane fusion protein works
similar
what we've been saying so now we have
fusion of the viral and endosome
envelopes triggered by low pH but the
capsid remains associated with the
outside of the endosome and it actually
doesn't completely come apart initially
it's just sitting on the surface here
and there's the idea is that a little
bit of the viral RNA is sticking out of
the capsid and as ribosomes engage it
they further dissociate the capsid and
start to translate this is a plus
stranded RNA virus so the first thing
that is happening is the viral RNA is
translated so here the fusion gets the
capsid out this is actually an
icosahedral capsid within an envelope
but then the capsid is not dissociate
it's just out of the envelope and what
does that is the ribosomes that begin to
pick out the RNA that's what they've
been taking about taking apart this
capsid so here here is another movie
dengue virus entry we're just full of
movies today and this is a in a similar
family of virus we've just talked about
it's taken up by endocytosis and it's
moving the endosome is moving along the
microtubules here's the virus inside see
this is one with a type 2 glycoprotein
now low pH the glycoproteins all stick
up so that they can trigger fusion so
that's a nice illustration of that
transition and this is a little wrong
because it's not near the the membrane
but anyway these are the glycoproteins
with the fusion proteins now sticking in
the endosome membrane they're going to
go do this hair pinning that I've talked
about and they make it insect-like for
some reason but you can see the net
result is that the membranes are brought
together okay and then eventually when
they do touch they fuse and that makes
the pore so that the viral capsid could
get out
okay I guess viral entry is amenable to
making movies because it's a dynamic
process right it's the one thing that
you can have multiple stages adenovirus
entry is interesting because it again
another mechanism here we have in a Casa
he drove virus there's no membrane so
how does the nucleic acid which is DNA
get out of it
the adenovirus binds a receptor via that
fiber it's taken up by endocytosis as
the pH drops in the endosome the capsid
these capsid contains proteins that are
conformed pores and membranes but
they're hidden there's sort of like
fusion proteins but but slightly
different and as the pH drops these
proteins which are normally hidden
become exposed in the capsid they
actually leave the capsid and they poke
a hole in the endosome so the virus one
of those accessory viral proteins that
we talked about before is buried in the
capsid it has the ability to lyse the
endosome but it's not released until low
pH is encountered so then the capsid
comes out of the lysed endosome docks
onto a microtubule which brings it to
the nuclear pore and there in docks and
associates and the DNA goes into the
nucleus and these are some electron
micrographs showing one of these
adenoviruses moving down a microtubule
and here is another of adenovirus docked
onto a nuclear pore complex so there's
there multiple lines of evidence for
this mode of entry
now poliovirus is another virus with a
capsid that doesn't have the ability to
fuse with the cell so how does the
nucleic acid get out it in this case the
receptor triggers the uncoding so in all
these cases remember we're going from a
metastable state to an unstable state
and we've seen how low pH is a major
component of that transition we've seen
how binding to receptors on the surface
and fusion protein exposure is for
adenovirus it is low pH also for polio
and a number of other viruses the
receptor is actually the catalyst
that brings the virus over that energy
barrier to the unstable state the virus
is taken up by endocytosis but very
shortly after these vesicles move
through the microfilaments the receptor
catalyzes the uncoding so what happens
is the receptor sits down on the
particle and it opened it causes a
conformational change that opens up a
pore at the fivefold axis of symmetry of
the particles so the receptor here's a
schematic of one fivefold axis here are
two receptor molecules sitting down on
the virus it causes a pore to open up at
the fivefold axis and here the RNA is
going through the pore now what forms
the pore one of the viral proteins which
is normally hidden on the interior it's
very hydrophobic finds the particle that
comes out this pore so sort of like a
fusion protein but it's not closing
membrane membrane fusion it's just
making a channel in this membrane now
the reason the receptor can do this is
that normally in the virion there's a
little channel beneath where the
receptor binds and that's occupied by a
lipid in the virus when the receptor
binds the lipid gets pushed out and that
gives the virus breathing space it can
structurally move around and open up a
pore here if this were occupied that
wouldn't be possible there are antiviral
drugs against polio and related viruses
that actually fit into that pocket so
the sphingosine normally fits into a
pocket just below where the receptor
binds there are antiviral drugs that
displace the lipid these bind very
tightly into the pocket and when the
virus binds the receptor the receptor
cannot catalyze this on coating because
the drugs stay locked into that pocket
okay and this is a schematic or this is
actually a structure of those drugs
bound in that little pocket this is
where the receptor would bind and these
are the drugs bound and this virus will
bind its receptor but it will never
unquote because the drugs prevent
on coding sometimes we need a
co-receptor for virus infection to occur
and this is illustrated by Coxsackie
Group B viruses which require two
receptors to get into cell they require
decay accelerating factor and a second
receptor car which is the Coxsackie as
no virus receptor the interesting thing
is that car receptor is a component of
tight junctions that is the junctions
between cells in an epithelial surface
it's not available on the apical surface
and I think we'll save the explanation
of this for next time we're going to
tell you about how these viruses in fact
get at this receptor which is in between
cells by disrupting the tight junctions
you